las mascarillas en interiores deben
volver incluso para los vacunados ese es
el mensaje actual de los centros para el
control y la prevención de enfermedades
estadounidenses en mayo la organización
estableció que las mascarillas no eran
necesarias para los vacunados por
completo una decisión que mantuvo
incluso la semana pasada pero nuevos
estudios y un rápido incremento de casos
revertieron esa postura
la ciencia demuestra ahora que incluso
la gente inoculada en caso de contraer
una infección irruptivo pueden
transmitir las meses por esta razón que
los cdc hicieron un cambio en la
recomendación changing recommendation el
doctor anthony fauci asesor médico en
jefe de kobe 19 dijo que los casos
irruptivo entre los vacunados son pocos
y también que son menos peligrosos con
el riesgo de hospitalización 20 veces
menos probable pero la transmisión a
otros se mantiene y la variante de venta
es altamente contagiosa
según la publicación académica
virológico investigadores encontraron
que la cantidad del virus en pacientes
con la variante delta es mil veces más
que en la primera ola
con solo 58 por ciento de
estadounidenses vacunados y con las
inoculaciones disminuyendo los contagios
están aumentando
tenemos una pandemia entre los no
vacunados y está generando una confusión
enorme tenemos que estar más preocupados
y alarmados y solo hay una cosa que
sabemos con certeza si aquellos 100
millones de personas se vacunarán
estaríamos en un mundo muy diferente la
administración baiden dijo que el
requerimiento para que todos los
empleados federales sean vacunados está
bajo consideración